This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Back in 1989, the engineers of Japan's famous Shinkansen bullet train realized they had a problem. The train was moving so fast that when it went into a tunnel, it basically punched the air out the far end, creating little sonic booms. All across Japan, the Shinkanzen was rattling buildings and disturbing residents in the neighborhoods it passed through. An engineering team was brought in to design a quieter and more efficient train, and they had a secret weapon. A.G. Nakatsu, the general manager of the technical development department, was a bird watcher. As he thought about the redesign, Nakatsu took inspiration from elements of his favorite birds, including owl feathers and penguin bellies. But the bird that inspired the most important element of the redesign was the kingfisher.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。早在 1989 年，日本著名新干线子弹头的工程师们意识到他们遇到了一个问题。列车行驶速度极快，当它驶入隧道时，基本上会把空气从远端挤压出去，产生微型的音爆。在日本各地，新干线列车发出的轰鸣声震动着建筑物，并打扰了沿线社区的居民。于是，一个工程团队被请来设计一款更安静、更高效的列车，而他们拥有一个秘密武器。技术开发部门的总经理中津昭（A.G. Nakatsu）是一位鸟类观察爱好者。在思考重新设计时，中津从他最喜欢的鸟类的身体结构中汲取了灵感，包括猫头鹰的羽毛和企鹅的腹部。但为这次重新设计提供最重要灵感的鸟类是翠鸟。
Kingfishers are famous for the elegant way they dive into the water to catch fish. Their uniquely shaped beaks allow them to break the surface of the water with barely a splash. And so Nakatsu and the Shinkansen design team decided to model the nose of their bullet trains off the Kingfisher's beak. And it worked. The new Shinkansen trains were quieter and more efficient. That Kingfisher redesign is now seen as a classic example of what's known as by, biomimicry, the act of looking to the non-human world for solutions to human design challenges. Biomimicry is simply design that is inspired by nature. Right.
翠鸟以其优雅的姿势潜入水中捕鱼而闻名。它们独特形状的喙能够使它们几乎不溅起水花就破水而入。因此，中津和新干线设计团队决定以翠鸟的喙为蓝本，设计子弹头列车的车头。这招奏效了。新款新干线列车不仅更安静，而且效率更高。翠鸟式的重新设计现在被视为“仿生学”（biomimicry）的一个经典案例，即从非人类世界中寻找人类设计挑战的解决方案。仿生学简而言之就是受大自然启发的设计。没错。
And I have to say that stories about biomimicry are catnip to design journalists like me. That is Kurt Kolestead, our resident design guy. Yep. And biomimicry, it's just this really inspiring concept, right? With all these fascinating examples, like the invention of the design. Elkrow being inspired by someone noticing how Burrs stuck to his dog's fur and to his jacket while he was out on a walk. Yeah. I mean, I love these stories.
我不得不说，关于仿生学的报道对于像我这样的设计记者来说简直是致命吸引力。那是库尔特·科尔斯蒂德（Kurt Kolstad），我们常驻的设计达人。没错。仿生学，这真是一个极其鼓舞人心的概念，对吧？有这么多迷人的例子，比如“魔术贴”（Velcro）的诞生，就是因为某人在散步时注意到芒刺粘在自己狗的毛皮和夹克上而受到的启发。对啊。我的意思是，我太喜欢这些故事了。
We love these stories on the show. We've covered biomimicry a lot over the years because the stories are just very catchy. Like, there is something so seductive about the idea of designers borrowing from nature to solve a human problem. It's just a very neat, simple, and just compelling narrative. Yeah, for sure. But recently, I've been digging into a bunch of biomimicry stories, and they are not always quite as neat and simple as that bullet train story. The causality is often quite a bit murkier than the headlines would have you believe. And the relationship between nature and human inspiration is often a lot more complicated. Yeah, and that actually makes biomimicry sound more interesting to me, not less. Like, I like that idea of a complex story, way better. Yeah, I agree. Same here. So today we're going to dive deeper, go beyond some simple headlines, separate some fact from fiction, and yeah, go into some more nuanced cases. But to kick things off and ground us in the concept, I want to start with a relatively straightforward, yet lesser known example of biomimetic design.
我们在节目中也非常喜欢这些故事。这些年来我们报道过很多次仿生学，因为这些故事实在太引人入胜了。例如，设计师从大自然中借鉴灵感来解决人类问题这种想法，有一种令人无法抗拒的魔力。这是一种非常精妙、简单且极具吸引力的叙事。是的，确实如此。但最近，我深入研究了一堆仿生学的故事，它们并不总是像那辆子弹头列车的故事那样完美和简单。因果关系往往比那些标题党让你相信的要模糊得多。自然与人类灵感之间的关系通常要复杂得多。是的，这实际上让仿生学听起来更有意思了，而不是变得无趣。比如，我更喜欢这种复杂的故事。是的，我同意。我也是。所以今天我们要深入探讨，超越那些简单的标题，去伪存真，探讨一些更有细微差别的案例。但为了开个好头并让我们扎根于这个概念，我想从一个相对直接但鲜为人知的仿生设计案例开始。
So this story takes place in the early 1800s in London, England. which was not yet that modern city that we know with its sophisticated transit network or really even basic sanitation. But it was already the largest city in the world and the largest port in the world. And when people needed to cross the city's famous Thames River, near that port, they took the London Bridge. But that bridge was notoriously crowded. It was like a choke point for everyday citizens and also commercial traffic, which really burying. burdened people as well as, you know, the city's commerce. And so over time, it became clear that another crossing downstream was desperately needed.
这个故事发生在 19 世纪初的英国伦敦，当时的伦敦还不是我们所熟知的那个拥有成熟交通网络甚至连基本卫生设施都算不上的现代化大都市。但它已经是当时世界上最大的城市和最大的港口。当人们需要穿过该市著名的泰晤士河（靠近那个港口）时，他们会走伦敦桥。但那座桥出了名的拥挤。它就像普通市民以及商业交通的瓶颈，这实际上给人们以及这座城市的商业带来了沉重的负担。因此随着时间推移，人们越来越清楚地意识到，迫切需要在下游再建一座过河通道。
Yeah, that makes sense to me. They needed another bridge. Totally. Except with the geography of the river and the port and the existing bridge, another bridge would have interfered severely with shipping access. So that solution was a non-starter. And the only real alternative was to tunnel under the river. But this is way before the tunnel to France or even the London Underground, so there was no precedent for tunnels going under active waterways.
是的，这对我来说很好理解。他们需要另一座桥。完全正确。不过考虑到河流、港口和现有桥梁的地理位置，再建一座桥会严重干扰航运通道。所以这个方案行不通。唯一真正的替代方案就是在河底下挖隧道。但这远在通往法国的隧道甚至伦敦地铁出现之前，所以没有任何在活跃水道下修建隧道的先例。
Tunneling technology at this point was essentially an extension of mining technology, right, dealing with solid rock and soil, but not the undersides of rivers. And so they tried to use those surface traditional mining techniques to tunnel under the Thames, but it ended in disaster, and in some cases the deaths of workers. And experts eventually came to conclude that this type of tunnel represented an impossible challenge. An engineer named Mark Brunel even wrote that prior attempts, quote, had so completely failed that he conceived all further exertions on the subject quite fruitless, as in it would be pointless to even try.
当时的隧道掘进技术基本上是采矿技术的延伸，处理的是坚硬的岩石和土壤，而不是河流的底部。因此，他们试图使用传统的地面采矿技术在泰晤士河下挖隧道，但结果以灾难告终，在某些情况下还导致了工人的死亡。专家们最终得出结论，这种类型的隧道是一个无法完成的挑战。一位名叫马克·布鲁内尔（Mark Brunel）的工程师甚至写道，先前的尝试“彻底失败了，以至于他认为所有进一步的努力都完全徒劳”，也就是说连尝试都没有意义。
But Brunel was about to have an experience that would completely, completely change his mind. Okay, so what happened? Well, I think it's best if I let him explain it. So here's an excerpt from a letter that he wrote to his granddaughter later on, recalling his time working for the British Royal Navy. And I'm just going to have you read it. About the year 1812, being then employed in the dockyard at Chatham, I happened to see before
但布鲁内尔即将经历一件彻底改变他想法的事情。好吧，那么发生了什么？嗯，我想最好由他亲自来解释。下面摘录了他后来写给孙女的一封信，回忆他在英国皇家海军工作的时光。我这就让你读一下。大约在 1812 年，当时我在查塔姆（Chatham）的造船厂工作，我碰巧看到我面前有一块被判废弃的木材，那是船龙骨的一部分，蛀虫——船蛆（Taredo Navalis）——在上面蛀蚀了许多孔洞。他说的“蛀蚀”是指隧道，就像穿过木头的隧道一样。好吧，用现代英语来说，就像他在码头上看到了一块被虫子吃掉的木头。对，差不多，差不多。除了所谓的“船蛆”实际上并不是一条虫子。实际上，它是一种结构奇特的双壳类软体动物。哦，就像蛤蜊一样？
me a piece of condemned timber, a portion of the keel of a ship, wherein the worm, the Taredo Navalis, had made many erosion. And by erosion, he means tunnels, like tunnels through the wood. Okay, so in modern English, like, he saw a piece of timber that had been worm eaten along the docks. Yeah, pretty much, pretty much. Except that the so-called naval shipworm is not actually a worm. In reality, it's a strangely adapted bivalve mollusk. Oh, like a clam?
对，对，只不过专门用来钻洞。它的工作原理是这样的。它的外壳已经进化成了一对研磨板。在这些板的后面拖着长而柔软、可以长到几英尺长的身体。我的意思是，听起来太可怕了。这听起来像是我以后会在小吃店里吃的东西。希望如此吧！希望它不会吃掉你，对吧？
Yeah, yeah, except specialized for boring holes. And it works like this. Like its shell has evolved into a pair of grinding plates. And behind those plates trails this long, soft, elongated body that can reach a couple of feet in length. I mean, it sounds terrifying. It sounds something that I would eat eventually at a tick as an appetizer. Hopefully, right? Hopefully it wouldn't eat you, right?
我的意思是，你在上面加点美景纳酱（minionette）。你知道的，把它挖出来。味道一定不错。好吧，是的。他没有走得那么远。但他确实掏出了一面放大镜——这是他随身携带的标志性物品——凑近仔细观察。当他观察时，他注意到这些虫子开凿的钻孔壁显得异常稳定。
I mean, you put some minionette on it. You know, like you scrape it out. It's going to be tasty. Well, yeah. And he didn't go quite that far. but he did pull out a magnifying glass, which is a thing that he was known to carry around, and went in for a closer look. And as he looked, he noticed that the walls of these boreholes that were carved by these worms seemed remarkably stable.
即使它们身处水淹且正在腐烂的旧船木块中，它们也得到了保护。所以这里又是布鲁内尔信中的原话：我当时对自己说，这些小东西开凿了小隧道，那么我们或许可以通过采用某种相应的保护手段。我的意思是，这基本上就是仿生学的教科书式定义。那么布鲁内尔注意到了船蛆是如何建造它们的隧道的？他认出并着手效仿的诀窍在于，船蛆同时做两件事。就在它们刮掉前方的木材并钻入洞中的同时，它们会分泌出一层内衬，用来涂抹和加固周围及身后的隧道。好吧。因此，在它们挖掘的同时，它们也立即加固了周围的隧道，这基本上描述了所有的挖掘工作。那么这与其他尝试有什么不同呢？
Even when they were in waterlogged and, like, rotting chunks of wood from old ships, they were protected. So here's Brunel again from that same letter. I then sent to myself that these little things have made little tunnels. so might we by adopting some corresponding means of protection. I mean, that's basically like the textbook definition of biomevergrain. So what did Brunel notice about how the shipworms made their tunnels? So the trick that he recognized and then set out to copy
嗯。所以可以这样想，对吧？习惯于在坚硬土壤中工作的矿工可以先挖一段，然后停一会，接着回去在身后架设支撑。没错。布鲁内尔认识到，这种迭代系统在泰晤士河下根本行不通，因为挖掘和加固之间的任何空间或时间间隙都会招致灾难。因此考虑到这一点，他在 1818 年去申请了一台机器的专利，这台机器的工作原理更像船蛆，即边挖掘边同时进行加固。那么布鲁内尔的机器是如何做到这一点的呢？嗯，关键部件被称为“盾构机”（tunneling shield）。基本上，它是一个巨大的铸铁框架，紧紧压在挖掘面上。在这个盾构机下面，有几十名矿工在隧道前沿凿岩，而泥瓦匠则在他们身后的隧道进行加固。因此随着挖掘的推进，盾构机会被向前推动，新暴露的部分会立即用水泥砖进行衬砌。这一切都是平稳连续作业的一部分，就像船蛆一样，一边开凿隧道，一边在身后进行加固。太酷了。是的，而且非常具有挑战性，因为（你知道的）布鲁内尔不得不把这个系统从所有这些移动的零件和人员中拼凑起来，因为当时的技术还不足以制造出一台能够将这一切自动化的机器，对吧？必须由人工来完成。最终，它成功了。这花了很长时间，而且过程并非一帆风顺。但布鲁内尔最终在 1843 年完成了横跨泰晤士河底一千多英尺的隧道。那是世界上任何地方在河流下方修建的第一条隧道。
was that shipworms do two things at the same time. Even as they scrape out the wood in front of them and move forward into that hole, they extrude a lining that coats and reinforces the, tunnel around and behind them. Okay. So while they dig, they also immediately shore up the tunnel around them, which describes basically all excavation. So how is this different from other attempts?
是的，我是说，双关语一下，这绝对是开天辟地（groundbreaking）之举。地球上从来没有人制造并走过这样一条隧道。而且还不止于此，因为布鲁内尔设计的那个盾构机塑造了后来的隧道掘进技术。多年以后，当他们在伦敦以及大洋彼岸的纽约建造地铁系统时，他们使用的就是那个基本的盾构机。太酷了。有趣的是，现代机器甚至与当初启发布鲁内尔的软体动物更加契合了。因为现在我们有了带有附件的机器，能够在掘进机向前钻洞的同时安装预制混凝土板。所以它就像那种一体化的东西。好吧。因此，尽管遇到了所有挫折，我们谈论的确实是一个非常直观的仿生学案例，比如自然界启发了人类的设计。一个人在自然界中看到某种东西，复制它，将其完善，砰，成功。
Yeah. Well, so think of it this way, right? Miners used to working in hard soil could get away with digging for a stretch and then stopping for a bit and then going back and putting up supports behind them. Right. And Brunel recognized that that kind of iterative system just was not going to cut it under the Thames because any gap in space or time between digging and shoring up invited disaster. And so with that in mind, in 1818, he went and patented a machine that would work more like a
是的，老实说，这就是我想从这里开始的原因，因为我想以一个成功的故事作为基础，在那个故事中，大自然确实是人类设计的直接灵感来源。但还有很多其他的故事并没有完全遵循那种清晰、直接的发展轨迹，在这些故事中，自然与人类设计灵感之间的关系并没有那么明确。好吧，我非常高兴能把水搅浑一点。接下来是什么？好吧，另一种带有真正曲折和离奇转折的鱼类仿生学，
shipworm, digging and then reinforcing simultaneously. So how did Brunel's machine do that? Well, the crucial piece was what he called a tunneling shield. Basically, it was this massive cast iron frame that was pressed flush against the face of the excavation. And under that shield, you would have dozens of miners chipping away at the front of the tunnel, while brick layers shored up the tunnel behind them. So as the excavation progressed, the shield would be pushed forward, and the newly exposed
时间要回到 2005 年，当时梅赛德斯-奔驰（Mercedes-Benz）推出了他们的“仿生概念车”（Bionic），在汽车界引起轰动。这是一款宣称具有仿生学起源故事的全新概念车。他们声称他们的设计是同类产品中第一个尝试“从自然到技术的完全转移”的设计。听起来像是含糊不清的废话。我甚至不知道那是什么意思。是的，好吧，他们的论点基本上是，仿生学通常涉及从动物身上借用单一特征或行为，比如鸟的羽毛或鲸鱼的鳍。
sections were immediately lined with cemented bricks. And so it was all part of this smooth and continuous effort, like the shipworm, tunneling and shoring up behind itself simultaneously. That's so cool. Yeah, and really challenging because, you know, Brunel had to piece together this system from all these moving parts and people because the technology at the time was not up to making like a machine that could automate all of this, right? It had to be people doing manual labor. And ultimately, it worked. It took a really long time and it did not always go smoothly. But eventually Brunel completed the tunnel spanning over a thousand feet under the Thames. in 1843. And that was the first tunnel built underneath a river anywhere in the world.
但他们的新车是以整个生物——箱鲀（boxfish）为蓝本的。这是它的照片。如果你脑海中浮现出一条方头方脑的鱼，因为它的名字叫箱鲀，那你就猜对了。我的意思是，它就是一个长着鳍的漂浮立方体。对，完全正确。它是这种外形奇特棱角分明的鱼类家族的一部分，其中包括牛鱼和箱鲀。是的。我的意思是（你知道的），与海军船蛆相比，这东西太可爱了。
Yeah, I mean, no. It was literally part in the pun, groundbreaking. Nobody on Earth had ever made and walked through a tunnel like this before. And it didn't stop there because Brudell's design that tunnel shield shaped
我的意思是，它就像是一条带有斑点的亮黄色鱼。但我不得不承认，这东西看起来一点也不符合空气动力学。这似乎与你会用来作为汽车设计蓝本的动物恰恰相反。那么以这种方盒子形状为汽车建模背后的逻辑是什么？嗯，从宏观来看（你知道的），梅赛德斯的工程师们对仿生学的概念很感兴趣，于是他们开始在动物王国中搜寻灵感。他们想知道，例如一条鱼是否能为汽车设计提供这种灵感。但汽车必须是方方正正的。
subsequent tunneling technology. Years later, when they built out subway systems in London and across the pond in New York, they used that same basic tunnel shield. That's so cool. And the funny thing is, modern machines have, if anything, converged even more on those
它们是容纳人类的空间。而一条细长的鱼永远无法转化为一辆功能齐全的汽车。因此，如果有一种方头方脑的鱼，经过进化既符合空气动力学又是方盒子形状，那可能是一个全方位适用的突破。好吧，是什么让他们认为箱鲀符合空气动力学？是的，嗯，这一切始于他们偶然发现的一项关于箱鲀的非常严肃的科学研究。
mollusks that originally inspired Brunel. Because now we have machines with attachments that place precast concrete panels as the borer tunnels onward. So it is like that all in one thing. Okay. So despite all the setbacks, we are really talking about a very straightforward case of biomimicry, like nature inspiring a human design. A guy sees something in nature, copies it, perfects it, boom, success.
特别是加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）、加州理工学院（Caltech）和伍兹霍尔（Woods Hole）的一个团队正在进行的科学研究。他们发现箱鲀的形状有一些细微的差别，有助于保持它的稳定性。基本上，箱鲀身体两侧有被称为“龙骨”（keels）的脊，这些脊有助于产生微小的涡流，从而帮助它们在水中游动时进行自我修正。我想这就是你希望保持汽车平稳行驶时所需要的，比如在高速公路上。就像你希望它保持稳定一样。所以这在某种程度上讲得通。
Yeah, and that's why I wanted to start here, honestly, because I wanted to ground us in a success story, where nature really was this direct inspiration for a human design. But there are a lot of other stories that don't perfectly follow that neat, direct trajectory, stories where the relationship between nature and human design inspiration is not quite so clear-cut. Okay, so I'm very excited to muddy the waters a little bit. So what is next? Well, a different sort of fishy biomimicry with some real twists and strange turns,
确实如此。在阅读了同行评议的研究论文后，梅赛德斯的工程师甚至主动联系并打电话给其中一位研究人员以了解更多关于他们的研究，然后他们又向前迈进了一步，进行了他们自己的研究。他们在这些鱼的三维模型周围进行了风阻测试，结果表明，尽管它们的脸呈方形，但它们出奇地流线型，至少在受控条件下是这样。因此，最终梅赛德斯的设计师得出结论，箱鲀尽管方方正正，但代表了“空气动力学的理想形态”。
starting back in 2005 when Mercedes-Benz made a big splash with their bionic, which was this new concept car that boasted a biomimetic origin story. They claimed their design was the first of its kind to attempt a, quote, complete transfer from nature to technology, end quote. Well, that sounds like vague nonsense. I don't even know what that means. Yeah, well, the argument was essentially that biomimicry usually involves borrowing like a single feature or behavior from an animal, like a bird's feather or a whale's fin.
而“仿生概念车”就是他们建造的那辆车，梅赛德斯建造的车。对，对，完全正确。他们不仅仅是设计了它。他们实际上把它造出来了。这是一张它的外观照片，对吧？这是一辆车，忠实于它的灵感来源，正如你所看到的，它相对方正。而且正如箱鲀那样，它沿着车身侧面也有这些带角度的脊，大同小异。对，对。
But that their new car was modeled on an entire organism, the boxfish. Here's a picture of it. If you were picturing a boxy fish because it's called a box fish, you're right on the money. I mean, like, it is a floating cube with fins. Yeah, exactly. And it's part of this family of really awkwardly angular fish, including the cowfish and the trunk fish. Yeah. I mean, you know, compared to the naval shipworm, this thing is adorable.
我的意思是，我现在正在看一张照片。它绝对是方方正正的。挺可爱的。我的意思是，它有点像一辆青柠绿的大众甲壳虫，（你知道的）带有某些更偏方形的特征。有点像面包车甲壳虫，你知道的，有点像。对。对。对，这是一个很好的描述。
I mean, it's like bright yellow with spots on it. But I have to admit, this thing doesn't look aerodynamic at all. Like, this seems like the opposite of an animal that you would model a car on. So what was the logic behind modeling a vehicle on this boxy shape? Well, big picture, you know, the engineers at Mercedes were into this idea of biomimicry, and so they started scouring the animal kingdom for inspiration. And they wondered if a fish, for example, could provide that inspiration for a car design. But cars have to be boxy.
说实话，我也觉得它挺可爱的。而且我不孤单。当梅赛德斯在一次盛大的公开活动中将这款车推向世界并置于聚光灯下时，它大受欢迎。仿生概念车的设计被《国家地理》杂志报道。它甚至被现代艺术博物馆（MoMA）收藏。有一段时间，它可能是世界上流传最广的汽车仿生学案例。是的，但我从来没见过这种车。所以我假设它从未走出概念车阶段，对吧？
They're spaces that house humans. And a long sleek fish is just never going to translate. into a functional car. And so if there is a boxy fish that has evolved to be aerodynamic and boxy, that really could be a breakthrough that works all around. Okay, but what made them think that the boxfish was aerodynamic? Yeah, well, it started with some real serious scientific research that they came across that was being done into the boxfish.
是的，没错。没有投入量产的商业汽车是从这演变而来的。这款仿生概念车确实从未真正走上公路。它只是一辆吸引了大量关注并被各种报道的概念车。但是（你知道的），从他们的角度来看，这从一开始就是主要目的。梅赛德斯可能没有推出一款可供销售的市售车，但他们确实获得了这个伟大的故事，帮助将他们的品牌与环保、前沿以及贯穿漫长岁月中有机元素自然设计的传统联系起来。好吧。但到目前为止，这似乎是一个非常直接的仿生学故事。
In particular, a study being run by a team spanning UCLA, Caltech, and woods hole. And so they discovered that there are nuances to the shape of the boxfish that help stabilize it. Basically, boxfish have these ridges that are called keels that run along their sides, and these help create little eddies, which help them horse correct as they swim through the water. Which I suppose is what you want to keep a car running smoothly, like on a highway. It's like you want it to be stable. So that makes some sense.
嗯，如果故事到此为止的话，确实如此。对梅赛德斯来说，基本上也确实如此。但鱼类科学家们（正如科学家们惯常做的那样）并没有停止研究。在仿生概念车首次亮相 10 年后，拥有新技术的研究人员发表了新发现，描绘了一幅截然不同的画面。旧数据并非完全错误。只是严重不完整。长话短说，事实证明，箱鲀在其整体性上绝对不是什么“空气动力学理想形态”。
Precisely. And after reading the peer-reviewed research papers, Mercedes-E. engineers even reached out and called up one of the researchers to learn more about their study, and then they took a step further and did research of their own. They had drag tests around 3D models of these fish that suggested that despite their squarish face, they were surprisingly streamlined, at least in controlled conditions. And so, in the end, Mercedes designers concluded that the boxfish, for all of its boxiness, represented a, quote, aerodynamic ideal, end quote.
事实上，如果非要说有什么不同的话，它基本上恰恰相反。那么他们发现了什么？嗯，由生物形态学研究员萨姆·范·瓦森伯格（Sam Van Wassenberg）领导的新团队模拟了那个钝而方正的前端一头扎进水中的情况。你看，如果它笔直前行的话，它的空气动力学表现确实还算可以，正如梅赛德斯得出的结论那样。但一旦这条鱼转过头去，它的空气动力学性能就会完全失稳。
And the bionic is the car that they built, the Mercedes built. Yeah, yeah, exactly. They didn't just design it. They actually built it. And here's a picture of what it looks like, right? It's a car which, true to its inspiration, is relatively boxy, as you can see. And it also has these angled ridges along the side that came from the boxfish, more or less. Yeah, yeah.
这听起来不像是汽车的好模型。是的，或者绝对不是他们设想的那样，因为事实证明箱鲀的超能力是机动性，而不是空气动力学。如果你真的观察它们，它们不是走直线游泳者或速度赛手。它们是这些礁鱼，它们花时间在珊瑚礁中穿梭并躲避捕食者。这些是需要瞬间转身的动物。
I mean, so I'm looking at a picture now. It is definitely boxy. It's pretty cute. I mean, it sort of looks like a lime green BW bug with, you know, some war-square-ish features. Kind of like a van bug, you know, kind of. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, that's a great description.
所以它们超级敏捷，可以摆动鱼鳍并在三维空间中旋转自己，这非常酷且对它们完全有用。但是，是的，这不是你在汽车中寻找的特性。而对于汽车，你希望有一种形状能够快速行驶，并且（你知道的）在一个方向上运行平稳，甚至在强风中也能保持航向。而箱鲀为了这些目的，
And honestly, I also think it's pretty cute. And I'm not the only one. When Mercedes put this car out into the world in the spotlight at a big public event, it was a hit. The bionic design got featured in Nat Geo. it was like installed in the MoMA. And for a while, it was probably the most widely circulated example of automotive biomimicry in the world. Yeah, but I haven't seen one of these. So I'm assuming it never got out of the concept car stage, right?
基本上是最糟糕的选择。所以这辆仿生概念车，它问世了。它引起了轰动。我敢肯定它在网上被广泛传播。当新研究出来时，梅赛德斯对此有任何回应吗？哦，没有。完全没有。事实上，仿生概念车的官方网页仍然将箱鲀描述为具有“高度流线型的身体形状”。
Yeah, that's right. There is no commercial car that evolved out of this. The bionic was really never truly made to go on the roads. It was just a concept car that got a bunch of attention and had a bunch of stories written about it. But, you know, like that from their perspective was kind of the whole idea in the first place. Mercedes might not have gotten a commercial car to sell, but they did get this great story that helped associate their brand with being like eco-friendly and cutting edge and tied into this legacy of natural design that had evolved in like the organic elements over the eons. Okay. But so far, this seems like a pretty straightforward biomimicry story.
等等，所以他们还在为这东西保留一个网页？对。是的，它还在那里。它仍然是他们营销材料的一部分。这东西的故事一直就是重点。这从来与汽车是否真的能运作无关。所以这种仿生学故事，你会把它归类为比泰晤士河隧道成功案例更典型的类型吗？就像这是我们尝试使用仿生设计时主要发生的事情吗？
Well, it would be if the story ended there. And for Mercedes, it basically did. But the fish scientists, like scientists do, kept going. And 10 years after the bionics big reveal, researchers with new technologies published new findings that painted a very different picture. The old data wasn't wrong exactly. It was just woefully incomplete. And long story short, it turns out that the boxfish, in its totality is definitely not a, quote, aerodynamic ideal.
是的，我会说（你知道的）失败绝对比成功更常见。但也有其他类型的非成功，比如基本上算是虚假的仿生灵感故事，或者至少是极大简化了的故事，对吧？没错。比如仅仅为了让产品听起来更有趣而编造一个仿生学故事。完全正确。有很多这样的例子。一个典型的例子是一家初创公司，声称自己发明了一种基于纳米比亚沙漠甲虫的水壶，
In fact, if anything, it's basically the exact opposite. So what did they find out? Well, the new team led by a biomorphology researcher named Sam Van Wassenberg, modeled that blunt boxy front plowing head on through the water. And look, it does do okay aerodynamically, as Mercedes had concluded, if it's going straightforward. But as soon as the fish turns its head, its aerodynamics are totally destabilized.
这是一种实际上已经进化出从稀薄空气中捕获水分方式的昆虫。它在背上收集并结合水滴，然后这些水滴顺流而下进入它的口中，这样它就可以饮用了。因此这些水壶（你知道的）基本上也会做同样的事情，并自行装满。好吧。既然我没听说过会自己装满水的水壶，我假设那根本没起作用。
Which doesn't sound like a great model for a car. Yeah, or definitely not the one they were envisioning, because it turns out that the boxfish's superpower is maneuverability, not aerodynamics. And if you actually watch them, they're not straight-line swimmers or speed racers. They are these reef fish, and they spend their days threading their way through reefs and evading predators. These are animals that need to turn on a dime.
是的，不，不，它实际上没有起作用。但它确实在《连线》（Wired）、美国国家公共电台（NPR）和英国广播公司（BBC）获得了大量报道。而且名单还在继续。他们甚至凭借那些甲虫筹集了数百万美元。所以，是的，这个水壶就像仿生概念车一样，与其说是真正的仿生学，不如说是公关作秀。老实说，我认为它甚至不像仿生概念车那样带有假装与科学联系的幌子。对，对。好吧，所以我们有一个成功的仿生学例子——隧道。
So they're super agile, and they flick their fins and rotate themselves in three dimensions, which is very cool and totally useful to them. But, yeah, it's not what you're looking for in a car. But the car you want a shape that can travel fast and, you know, run smooth in one direction, even in high winds, just sort of stay on course. And the box fish, for those purposes,
我们有梅赛德斯的例子，这确实是营销上的成功，但作为产品并不成功。接下来是什么？老实说，这是一个比前两者更复杂、更不直观的故事。好的，我们休息一下再讲。欢迎回来，我们继续与库尔特·科尔斯蒂德（Kurt Kolstad）探讨仿生学。我们的最后一个故事是关于一种结构设计，你基本上可以在航空航天工业的任何地方找到它。如果你剥开波音飞机或美国宇航局航天飞机上的面板，你会看到一排排六边形。这些被称为蜂窝夹层面板。它们看起来像蜂巢，会瞬间让你联想到蜂巢。
was essentially the worst fish to choose. So the biotic, it came out. It had a big splash. It was like sent around, I'm sure, online a lot. When the new research came out, did Mercedes respond to it at all? Oh, no. Not at all. And in fact, the Bionics official web page still describes the boxfish as having a, quote, highly streamlined body shape.
是的，所以是蜂窝面板。我以前绝对见过。我想任何稍微关注过结构的人以前都见过。哦，是的。它们是从蜜蜂身上获得灵感吗？嗯，这个看似简单的问题其实出奇地难以回答。因为如果你仔细想想（你知道的），人们自古以来就一直在赞美和检查蜂巢。比如我们拥有的关于它们为什么会创造六边形形状的最早文字记录可以追溯到公元前 37 年。正是在这段时间里，几何学家们发现六边形是仅有的三种可以连续平铺且没有缝隙的形状之一。
Wait, so they still have a webpage for this thing? Yeah. Yeah, it's still up there. It's still like part of their marketing material. It's like the story of this thing was always the point. It was never about whether the car actually worked. So this kind of biomimicry story, would you classify it as more typical than like the TAMS tunnel success? Like is this the type of thing that is mostly what happens when we try to use biomimetic design?
还有正方形，你当然可以在网格中想象它们。是的，就像我们的标志。对，对。还有三角形，就像你能想象一个桁架，或者如果你只是上下交错，你可以看到它们永远平铺下去，对吧？然后就是六边形。
Yeah, I would say that, you know, failures are definitely more common than successes. But there's also like other kinds of non-successes, like basically sort of fake stories. of having biomimetic inspiration, or at least like vastly simplified ones, right? Right. Like just telling a biomimicry story about a product just so it sounds more interesting. Exactly. And there are a lot of those. And a classic example is this startup that claimed to have invented a water bottle based on the Namib Desert Beetle,
在所有这些组合中，六边形是能为你提供最多空间的形状，即每个边缘单位面积最大。这意味着如果你在平铺一系列形状，这些形状能让你使用最少的材料。因此对蜜蜂来说，这更有效率，并且使建造更容易。但人类也从这种效率和其他结构特征中受益，我们稍后会讲到。所以在这种情况下，因为这是一个针对许多问题的超高效结构解决方案，蜜蜂和工程师们（你知道的）基本上只是想出了相同的解决方案。这对我来说完全说得通。但在现代，另一群人出现了，将蜂巢视为智能设计的例子。在 19 世纪，一位牧师兼自然主义者赞美蜜蜂是“受天堂启发的数学家”。甚至在 19 世纪 50 年代达尔文撰写《物种起源》时，他也将这种思维方式视为对他工作的巨大威胁。
which is this insect that has actually evolved a way to capture water out of thin air. It collects and combines droplets on its back. and then those trickle down to its mouth so it can drink them. And so these water bottles were, you know, going to do that same thing, essentially, and fill themselves up. Right. Like, since I haven't heard of a self-filling water bottle, I assume that that just didn't work.
哈。那么为什么蜜蜂擅长几何会成为进化论的问题呢？好问题。基本上，如果进化是渐进的，对吧，蜜蜂是如何得出完美几何图形的？比如，它们采取了哪些步骤？因为（你知道的），一个稍微偏离的不完整六边形并不是朝着制造一个好六边形迈出的自然一步。它只是一种糟糕的形状。那么我们在哪里能找到中间版本呢？
Yeah, no, no, it did not actually work. But it did get so much coverage in Wired and NPR and BBC. And like the list goes on. They even raised millions of dollars on the backs of those Beatles. So, yeah, the water bottle, like the bionic, it was really more about PR than real biomimicry. And honestly, it had less pretensions to even tie to science, I think, than the bionic did. Yeah, yeah. Okay, so we have one example of successful biomimicry with the tunnel.
如果没有这些版本，自然神学论点就会认为，某个存在或某种神必定把答案交给了蜜蜂。另外，我怀疑这一切背后还有一种直觉上的本能。比如，如果你环顾自然界，你会看到曲线、分形和所有这些混乱的东西，但精确的有角多边形是非常奇怪且罕见的。因此它们在视觉上似乎是个打破常规的例外，对吧？没错，没错。所以我能理解这个论点，或者为什么它很复杂。这就是让达尔文担心的原因吗？
We have the Mercedes example, which is really, you know, a success in marketing, but not really successful as a product. So what's next? Something that is, honestly, a little more complicated and less straightforward than either of those. Okay, we'll get to that after the break. So we're back talking about biomimicry with Kirk Holstead. So our final story is about a structural design that you can find basically anywhere in the aerospace industry. If you peel back a panel on a Boeing plane or a NASA shuttle, you'll see an array of hexagons. And these are called honeycomb sandwich panels. They look like and will instantly remind you of beehives.
是的。事实上，以至于他在撰写《物种起源》时还专门养蜂来做研究和实验。他观察到的是，蜜蜂并不是直接建造六边形的。它们实际上开凿的是圆形的洞，嗯，基本上就是蜜蜂形状的洞，对吧？是的。但当许多蜜蜂在网格中这样做时（你知道的），它们最终会互相碰撞。当它们接近邻居时，它们会自然地在这些共享边缘周围建造墙壁，这就会变成六边形。没错。所以它们从未真正建造出六边形的形状。就像它们挖了一个圆洞，然后你竖起一些墙来支撑。它们被做着同样事情的其他邻居包围着，圆洞的侧面相互推挤并变平，从而得到了一个六边形。完全正确。这并不是说蜂巢不是自然奇观。事实上，达尔文是它的超级粉丝，在他完成对这些蜜蜂的研究后，他围绕它们和它们的蜂巢组织了《物种起源》中的整整一章，在其中他认为这些是进化力量的惊人例证。这里是那一章的一小段节选：一个人如果不怀着狂热的赞赏去审视一个如此完美适应其目的的蜂巢的精致结构，他一定是个迟钝的人。我们从数学家那里听说，蜜蜂实际上把它们的细胞做成了合适的形状，以容纳尽可能多的蜂蜜，而在它们的建设中消耗最少量的珍贵蜂蜡。而且（你知道的），这些联系本来就已经存在了，但当达尔文出版《物种起源》时，蜜蜂和六边形就紧密结合在这本世纪最受欢迎的科学书中，并且自此基本上密不可分。因此，在大约一个世纪后达尔文时代制作六边形面板时，它们理所当然地被命名为了蜂窝面板。
Yeah, so honeycomb panels. I've definitely seen them before. I think anyone who's paid attention to structures at all have seen them before. Oh, yeah. Were they inspired by bees? Well, that seemingly simple question is actually surprisingly difficult to answer. Because if you think about it, like, people have been admiring and examining honeycombs since ancient times. Like the earliest written account we have of why they might create hexagonal shapes dates back to 37 BC. And it was around this time that geometers had figured out. that hexagons are one of only three shapes that you can tile continuously
对，对。我的意思是，你只是根据它们看起来像什么来命名它们（你知道的）？这对我来说说得通。但在仿生学方面，在我们今天的主题方面，那些使用蜂窝形状的航空航天工程师，他们是在建立在蜜蜂的逻辑之上，还是在建立在先于他们的人类研究人员的传统之上？
and without gaps. There are squares which of course you can visualize in a grid. Yeah, like our logo. Yeah, yeah. And triangles, which like if you can picture a truss or if you just kind of alternate up and down, you can see those tiling forever, right? And then there are hexagons.
我的意思是，是的。我会说两者皆有，以上皆是。我更喜欢这种模棱两可的感觉。就像从自然到人类没有一条简单的直线。而且（你知道的），经过 2,000 多年的蜂巢历史将我们带入现代航空航天工业，你可能会认为这将是故事的结局。但我为你们准备了最后一个小转折。哦，太棒了。好的，我想听更多。
And of all that set, hexagons are the ones that give you the most space as in the most area per unit of edge. Which means that if you're tiling an array of shapes, these are the ones that let you use the least material. So for bees, that's more efficient and it makes building easier. But humans benefit from that same efficiency and other structural features, which we'll
好的。所以在 2010 年代末，这位名为德鲁·巴蒂（Drouv Batee）的 3D 打印专家开始思考蜂巢。他想知道除了这种特定六边形多边形的柏拉图式理想之外，它们是否还有更多内容。因此他寻求了一位专家的帮助——一位在亚利桑那州立大学（Arizona State）实际仿生学中心工作的昆虫学家克林特·佩尼克（Clint Pennick）。克林特惊讶地发现，德鲁一生都在从事蜂窝结构的研究，却从未在现实生活中见过真正的蜂巢。你知道吗？我在科学界工作了很长时间。这其实并不让我感到意外。
get to later. So in this case, because this is a super efficient structural solution to lots of problems, bees and engineers, you know, kind of just came up with the same solution. That makes total sense to me. But in the midst of the modern era, another. contingent came along and saw honeycombs as examples of intelligent design. In the 1800s, one clergyman slash naturalist lauded bees as, quote, heaven-instructed mathematicians, end quote. Darwin actually saw this line of thinking as a big threat to his work, even in the 1850s as he was writing on the origin of species.
对。是的。因为（你知道的），大多数工程师不需要费心去了解蜜蜂。他们知道这个形状，对吧？但克林特看到了这一点，他开始向德鲁展示真正的蜂巢，他们一起开始观察这些蜂巢如何因物种而异，他们观察到真正的蜂巢与那些人类制造的僵硬重复的蜂窝面板实际上有相当大的不同。好吧。那么它们有什么不同呢？
Huh. So why would the bees being good at geometry be a problem for evolution? Great question. And so basically, if evolution is incremental, right, how do bees arrive at a perfect geometry? Like, what are the steps they take? Because, you know, a slightly off incomplete hexagon isn't a natural step towards making a good hexagon. It's just a bad shape. And so where do we find the in-between versions?
嗯，最容易发现的区别是在角落里，在这些人类蜂窝面板中呈尖角的交叉点，但在自然界中通常有不同程度的圆润度。是的。我的意思是，这对我来说说得通，因为正如达尔文所描述的（你知道的），蜜蜂有点像在做一个圆圈，然后它变成了六边形。所以就像没有其他圆圈围绕着你意味着边缘更圆润一样。对，对，对。因此克林特和德鲁使用 3D 打印来复制这些曲线。他们发现这些曲线可以提供真正的结构优势。最终，这对搭档获得了美国宇航局（NASA）的资金支持，以进行更深入的研究。他们对数十种不同种类的蜜蜂和黄蜂的这些不同蜂巢进行了 X 光透射和特征分析，并记录了各种较小的细节，比如壁厚的差异以及独立蜂巢部分如何连接在一起的各种方式。果然，蜂巢形状的更微妙的元素被发现可以改善结构性能，并具有潜在的航空航天应用。
And if there aren't any, the natural theological argument goes, somebody or some God must have handed the bees the answer. Also, I suspect there was kind of a gut-level intuition behind all of this. Like, if you look around at the natural world, you see curders and fractals and all these chaotic things, but precise angular polygons are pretty weird. and rare. And so they seemed just visually, like an exception to the norm, right? Right, right. So I can sort of see the argument or why it was complicated. And that was what
哇。所以，即使在太空时代，蜜蜂建造的六边形也比我们做的好。是的，我的意思是，这取决于蜜蜂和应用场景。但我们绝对仍在向它们学习东西，这太疯狂了。哈。
had Darwin worried? Yeah. In fact, so much so that he actually kept bees to research and experiment on while he was writing origin. And what he observed is that bees don't build hexagons outright. They actually dig roundish holes that are, well, basically B-shaped, right? Yeah. But when a bunch of them do that, you know, in a grid, they end up bumping into each other. And as they approach their neighbors, they naturally make walls around those shared edges, and that turns into hexagons. Right. So they never really build a hexagon shape. Like they dig a round hole and you put up some walls for support. And they're surrounded by other neighbors who are doing. the same thing, and the sides of the circular holes kind of push against each other and flatten
我喜欢这个故事。我的意思是，这让我想到了我们开始时讨论的那个非常简单的仿生学故事——翠鸟与子弹头列车的故事。你知道，这很酷。很容易传达。但相比之下，它显得相当扁平且索然无味。嗯，我的意思是，我不知道我是否会走那么远，因为对于那些直接的仿生学故事，我确实依然有些情有独钟。
out so that you get a hexagon shape. Exactly. None of which is to say that honeycombs aren't natural wonders. In fact, Darwin was a huge fan, and after he finished his research with these bees, he organized a whole section of origin around them and their honeycombs in which he argued that these were amazing examples of the power of evolution. And here's a little excerpt from that chapter. He must be a dull man who can examine the exquisite structure of a comb
但当然，是的，像蜂巢故事这样的故事最终也更丰富，其中人类创造力和大自然最终卷入了这种更复杂的来回对话中。是的，就像大自然和人类之间关于形状优点的递归讨论，我猜。库尔特，这太有趣了。我很感激这次对各种仿生学的游览。当然，罗曼。随时奉陪。本周的 99% Invisible 由库尔特·科尔斯蒂德（Kurt Kolstad）报道，雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森（Jacob Medina Gleason）制作，埃姆特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）编辑。混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martine Gonzalez）完成。
so beautifully adapted to its end without enthusiastic admiration. We hear from mathematicians that bees have practically made their cells of the proper shape to hold the greatest possible amount of honey with the least possible consumption of precious wax in their construction. And, you know, there were already all of these connections, but when Darwin published origin, honeybees and hexagoners, became stuck together in one of the most popular science books of the century and were essentially inextricably linked ever since. So when hexagonal panels are created around a century after Darwin,
音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）制作。事实核查由格雷姆·赫沙（Graham Hesha）完成。凯茜·2（Kathy 2）是我们的执行制片人。德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、薇薇安·莱（Vivian Lay）、洛沙·马顿（Losha Madon）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）。
of course, they get named honeycomb panels. Right, right. I mean, you're just naming them after what they look like, you know? Like, that makes sense to me. But in terms of biomimicry, in terms of our subject today, were the aerospace engineers who were using the honeycomb shapes, were they building off of the logic of bees, or were they building off the legacy of human researchers who came before them?
当然，它们被称为蜂窝板。对，对。我的意思是，你只是根据它们的外观来命名，对吧？就像，这对我来说很有意义。但就仿生学而言，就我们今天的主题而言，那些使用蜂窝形状的航空航天工程师，他们是借鉴了蜜蜂的逻辑，还是借鉴了他们之前的那些人类研究者的遗产？
I mean, yes. I would say both, all the above. And I rather dig that ambiguity. Like, there is no simple straight line from nature to humans. And, you know, after 2,000-plus years of honeycomb history bringing us to the modern aerospace industry, you might think that that would be the end of the story. But I have one last little twist for you. Oh, awesome. Okay, I want to hear more.
我的意思是，是的。我想说两者都是，以上皆是。而且我相当喜欢这种模糊性。就像，从自然到人类之间没有一条简单的直线。而且，你知道，在经历了2000多年的蜂窝历史将我们带入现代航空航天工业之后，你可能会认为这将是故事的结局。但我最后还有一个小转折要告诉你。哦，太棒了。好的，我想听更多。
Yeah. So in the late 2010s, this 3D printing expert named Drouv Batee got to thinking about honeycombs. And he wondered if there was maybe more to them than this platonic ideal of this particular six-sided polygon. So he sought out an expert, an endomologist named Clint Pennick, who was working. working at an actual biomimicry center at Arizona State. And Clint was shocked to discover that Drew, who had built a whole career on honeycomb structures, had never even seen an actual honeycomb in real life. You know what? I worked in science for a long time.
是的。所以在2010年代末，一位名叫德鲁·巴蒂的3D打印专家开始思考蜂窝的问题。他想知道，除了这种特定六边形多边形的柏拉图式理想之外，它们是否还有更多的内涵。因此，他寻找了一位专家，一位在亚利桑那州立大学的一个实际仿生学中心工作的昆虫学家克林特·佩尼克。克林特惊奇地发现，德鲁一生都在从事蜂窝结构的研究，却从未在现实生活中见过真正的蜂窝。你知道吗？我从事科学研究很长时间了。
This actually does not surprise me. Right. Yeah. Because, you know, most engineers, they don't need to bother with bees. They know the shape, right? But Clint sees this and he starts showing droove actual honeycombs, and together they begin to look at how these vary by species, and they observe that real honeycombs are actually quite a bit different from those sort of rigidly repetitive human-made honeycomb panels. All right. So how did they differ?
这其实并不让我感到意外。对。是的。因为，你知道，大多数工程师，他们不需要去管蜜蜂。他们知道形状，对吧？但克林特看到了这一点，他开始向德鲁展示真正的蜂窝，他们一起开始研究这些蜂窝是如何因物种而异的，他们观察到真正的蜂窝实际上与那些僵硬重复的人造蜂窝板有相当大的不同。好的。那么它们有什么不同呢？
Well, the easiest difference is at the corners, at these intersections that are sharply angled in human honeycomb panels, but in nature often have different degrees of round-tecum. Yeah. I mean, that makes sense to me because, as Darwin described, you know, like the bees are kind of making a circle and it turns into a hexagon. So like not having other circles around you means that the edges are more rounded. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And so Clint and Drew used 3D printing to replicate those curves. And what they found is that they can offer real structural benefits. So ultimately, the pair got NASA funding to look even more closely. And they x-rayed and characterized these different combs from. dozens of different species of bees and wasps, and they documented all kinds of smaller details, like the variations in the wall thicknesses and the way that separate comb sections are, like, joined together. And sure enough, subtler elements of the comb shape
好吧，最容易发现的区别在于角落，在人造蜂窝板中这些交界处是呈锐角的，但在自然界中往往有不同程度的圆润。是的。我的意思是，这对我来说很有意义，因为正如达尔文所描述的，你知道，蜜蜂就像是在做一个圆，然后它变成了一个六边形。所以，周围没有其他的圆意味着边缘更加圆润。是的，是的，是的。因此，克林特和德鲁用3D打印来复制这些曲线。他们发现的是，它们可以提供真正的结构优势。最终，这对搭档获得了美国宇航局的资金支持，以便进行更仔细的研究。他们对来自几十种不同蜜蜂和黄蜂的这些不同的蜂巢进行了X光透射和特征分析，并记录了各种较小的细节，比如壁厚的变异以及不同的蜂巢部分是如何连接在一起的。果不其然，蜂巢形状的更微妙的元素
were found to improve structural performance with potential aerospace applications. Wow. So, like, even in the space age, bees are building better hexagons than we do. Yeah, I mean, it depends upon the bee and the application. But we are definitely still learning stuff from them, which is crazy. Huh.
被发现可以改善结构性能，并具有潜在的航空航天应用价值。哇。所以，即使在太空时代，蜜蜂也比我们建造出更好的六边形。是的，我的意思是，这取决于蜜蜂和应用场景。但我们绝对仍在向它们学习东西，这太疯狂了。哈。
I love that story. I mean, it makes me think about the, you know, the very simple biomimicry story that we started with, the sort of Kingfisher, Bullet Train story. You know, it's cool. It's easy to convey. But it's pretty flat and flavorless by comparison. Yeah. Well, I mean, I don't know if I'd go that far because there's something I really still dig about those straightforward biomimicry stories.
我喜欢那个故事。我的意思是，这让我想起了，你知道的，我们开始时的那个非常简单的仿生学故事，那种翠鸟与子弹头列车的故事。你知道，这很酷。很容易传达。但相比之下，它相当扁平且乏味。是的。好吧，我的意思是，我不知道我是不是会走那么远，因为对于那些简单的仿生学故事，我确实还有一些非常喜欢的地方。
But sure, yes, there is something also richer, ultimately, about ones like, the honeycomb story where you have human creativity and nature ending up in this more complex back and forth conversation with one another. Yeah, like a recursive discussion between nature and humans about, you know, the virtues of shapes, I guess. Kurt, this was so much fun. I appreciate this tour through various kinds of biomimicry. Of course, Roman. Anytime. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Kurt Kolstad, produced by Jacob Medina Gleason and edited by Emmett Fitzgerald. Mix by Martine Gonzalez.
但当然，是的，像蜂窝故事这样最终更丰富的的故事也有其独特之处，在那里你有人类的创造力和大自然最终在这场更复杂的来回对话中相互交流。是的，就像大自然和人类之间关于形状优点的递归讨论，我猜。库尔特，这太有趣了。我很感激这次对各种仿生学的参观。当然，罗曼。随时。99% Invisible本周由库尔特·科尔斯塔德报道，雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森制作，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德编辑。马丁·冈萨雷斯混音。
Music by Swan Real. Fact-checking by Graham Hesha. Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason DeLeon, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Losha Madon, Joe Rosenberg,
天鹅真实乐团配乐。格雷姆·赫沙核查事实。凯茜2号是我们的执行制片人。德兰妮·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·莱、洛莎·马顿、乔·罗森伯格、
Kelly Prime, Talon and Rain Stradley, and Me Roman Mars. The 99% of the visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Serious XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora Building,
Kelly Prime、Talon、Rain Stradley以及我，Roman Mars。可见标志的99%由Stefan Lawrence创作。我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在向北六个街区外的潘多拉大厦，
in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites, as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心上城。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有一个链接，以及99PI过去的每一集，网址是99PI.org。本集暂时还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。